Speaker 1: the weekend that we just had trying
to figure out the right words.
It's not funny anymore, guys.
If it ever was and it was never funny to many
of us, if it ever was, this Trump cult is
not funny anymore.
They are motivated.
Tens of millions of them still want Trump
again.
They are willing to travel.
They are willing to pay just to hear from
the guy.
He is increasingly the dangerous cult leader.
They are increasingly the dangerous cultists.
I just finished reading Jeff Gwen's great
book about Charles Manson.
And when I read about the followers of Manson
and what they were willing to do in their
case, they were willing to kill.
It's hard not to think about Trump cultists,
and the danger of this group of people cannot
be overstated.
There was a rally in Michigan over the weekend.
We're going to look at what Trump said.
We're going to look at what the speaker said.
We're going to look at what the attendees
said.
And one of the things that is concerning is
the Trumpists who now come across my streams
of these events.
They are angrier than ever.
They used to ignore my coverage of these rallies
before now.
Dozens and dozens of them will e-mail me furious.
Maybe it's because they are angry that he
lost and he's no longer president.
Maybe it's because they are emboldened.
Maybe it's because they don't like that.
Trump is making no sense whatsoever at these
rallies, but for whatever reason, they are
very, very triggered by our coverage of these
rallies.
Let's start with the things that Donald Trump
said yesterday.
It was a very glitzy night.
There were like five or six of those weird
glitch twitch issues.
I'm not going to play all of them.
Here's one where I guess he was trying to
talk about Zuckerberg drop boxes and he just
glitched, and it was very strange.
Speaker 2: The elimination of Zuckerberg drug.
But I call him the unlock boxes,
Speaker 1: and it's always that shoulder glitch,
right?
When he makes a mistake.
It's not clear what it is.
We don't know.
Is it neurological?
Is it psychological?
We don't know.
There were half a dozen of them yesterday.
I won't bore you with more of them.
We're used to it up at this.
Up until this point in time, I made a good
faith effort to find anything that Trump said
that was true.
And here's the best I came up with.
Trump said at one point during the rally in
Russia, there is such a rigged press that
some Russians don't even really understand
the nature of the war that is going on.
That was true.
Everything else, he said, was false.
You know,
Speaker 2: they say that in Russia, the people
in Russia don't even know they're having a
war because they have a rigged press.
We have the same rigged press, maybe not quite
as severe, but it'll be there in the not too
distant future.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, that last part
isn't true, although Trump would love to have
a rigged press that only praises him, but
that is not true.
As crazy as this is going to sound, Donald
Trump floated the idea of going back to Afghanistan.
He said, what we might go back and the crowd
cheered, Guys, I can't do it.
I can't do it.
It was years of saying he would get us out
and he failed to do it.
And then Biden got us out, and now Trump is
so upset with how Biden got us out that he
says, maybe we'll go back and get our stuff.
And the crowd cheers, understand we're talking
about in order to do that, you've got to send
troops back in and the crowd cheers.
It's beyond belief.
Speaker 2: Do you have many citizens that
the Taliban is holding?
They didn't get enough with the $85 billion.
Maybe we ought to go in and take it back.
Dumbest thing I've ever seen.
Go back in.
Finest military equipment in the world they
have come from, the guy goes to the 700000
machine guns.
Speaker 1: It is.
It is incredible.
I'm not aware of Trump ever having mentioned
Joe Biden's White House press secretary, Jen
Psaki, before.
But he did at the Saturday rally, and he referred
to her as the woman with the really beautiful
red hair.
Just there can.
He can't talk about anything in a normal way.
Here is Trump on Jen Psaki
Speaker 2: and then the woman with a really
beautiful red hair.
She left, and she was hit so hard by the military
because they knew I was right.
The military understood I was right.
You know she's going to miss the ANC.
You know that
Speaker 1: right?
It does appear, it does appear that Jen Psaki
is going to be when she leaves going to MSNBC.
That act.
So I guess Trump told two truths in his nearly
two hour speech.
Speaker 2: They need a redhead.
They don't have a redhead over there, so they
need to read her
Speaker 1: very slurry, as you can imagine
in the crowd.
Just absolutely loving all of it.
Here is another lie that Trump continues to
tell Trump once again claiming that he was
the recipient of an award that does not exist.
They get
Speaker 2: worse.
And then I was named a long time ago, I was
named.
Did you know this a long time?
I don't know your Chamber of Commerce.
Somebody who the hell knows what it is.
They named me the Man of the Year in Michigan,
and I got up.
And I said they're stealing your car business.
And I was really rebuild this, and that wasn't
a very nice thing to say, I said.
Speaker 1: But now two things one, I don't
know why Trump was so sweaty throughout the
entire event.
Many of our viewers were asking that on Saturday
night, but that award doesn't exist.
The crowd cheers anyway.
It doesn't matter whether, you know, if you
go this, this is the sick reality, guys.
This Trump's been claiming he got this award
Man of Michigan Man of the Year for a very
long time.
There's no evidence that it exists.
So it's been researched by multiple media
outlets they tried.
Since 2016, media outlets have been trying
to verify that Trump got this award.
There's no evidence he got it.
There's no evidence the award exists.
If you go to a Trumpist and say, you know,
that award doesn't exist here, they would
come up with something like, Well, he should
have gotten that award.
That award should exist.
It should be created.
It should be given to Donald Trump.
This is how delusional these cultists are.
Now, at another point in the rally, Trump
made a completely unintelligible rant about
We figured out later he's talking about Jeff
Fortenberry, birth Fortenberry, who was convicted
of lying to the FBI and concealing information
criminal.
OK?
And Trump seemed to sort of be making light
of what happened to Jeff Fortenberry, but
it didn't make any sense.
Listen to
Speaker 2: this.
Million dollars, you know, in a great state,
Nebraska, a congressman is being put in jail
over a few dollars that he possibly didn't
even know anything about.
He's going to jail a few thousand dollars.
And yet this guy gives 417 million dollars
to all these states.
The money, it's passed around like a like
pizza, like pizza at a party, and nothing
happens to him.
They're putting this congressman.
I don't know him well, but he's a congressman.
And it was over a very small amount of money.
They're going to put him in jail over a number
of thousands, like $20000,
Speaker 1: that it first was like no money
and then it was thousands.
And then then, then it's 20000.
Jeff Fortenberry was convicted of lying to
the FBI.
Like many Trump associates have done, concealing
information in an investigation about illegal
contributions made by a foreign national to
his reelection campaign.
Does that ring a bell to anybody?
Sounds very similar to some of the investigations
into the people around Trump.
Trump then had a sort of dog whistle attack
on primarily but not exclusively black athletes
who have knelt during the national.
Or is it knelt or kneeled during the national
anthem, saying, You only kneel, you don't
kneel or we look at
Speaker 2: you and Americans kneel to God
and God alone.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah.
OK, so you guys get the implication you don't
kneel during the anthem, you only kneel to
God.
My sense is Trump's never been on his knees
for Jesus in his life.
That's my sense of the guy.
And then lastly, Trump starts to do sort of
like impression of how he would do a concession
speech, but then he stops for fear that the
media will edit it in an unfair way or
Speaker 2: be a lot easier for me to do.
Like many people have done, get up and just
say congratulations, whoever it is I'm running
against.
I mean, if you're running, I say, Congratulations,
Joe.
Now watch, if I say it, I don't want to say
it because they'll put it on.
Like, This is what they do.
Whoa.
Remember the Russia if you're listening thing?
So they cut it off immediately because it
was a joke.
Russia, if you're listening to do this or
that with her emails or whatever the hell
are, they are.
And then I laugh.
They left.
The whole place was left, but they cut it
off immediately.
So Russia DLC cut.
Speaker 1: Nobody cut it off there.
That is a lie.
Nobody cut it off there.
So this is the dangerous cultist.
He has followers.
He has influence.
They're not going away.
Let's now look at some of the other people
who spoke at
the rally.